even even though I've been talking about
guys that said I I only exclusively date
outside my ratio I think the thing that
a lot of black women need to understand
because this isn't a show about like you
know talking bad this is just being real
and honest like yeah everybody's gonna
say their part yeah
um I need you not to understand that I
have a lot of black guys even ones that
are dating that say exactly what this
brother said that black women are his
preference or are their preference but
the problem is there's a disconnect like
do you get what I'm saying there's a
disconnect whether it be the cause of
feminism whether it be the cause of you
know um social engineering from the
music movies you know stripper culture
whatever you know fathers not being in
the homes etc etc and it's caused the
rift and you know it's caused a lot of
frustration and then a lot of times a
lot of times that frustration can
manifest and it can look like oh you
hate us you know what I'm saying and
it's not necessarily that do you get
what I'm saying
um another aspect I would say is that um
in general I feel like or I know that
women tend to have a problem with taking
accountability and and realizing that
right I may need self-development I
think men are more income trying to take
on the fact that okay I'm not the best
version of myself I can I need to fix
myself up so I can get the kind of woman
that I want whereas a lot of times women
are like Take Me As I Am do you get what
I'm saying like oh you should like the
way I am and I'm sorry it just doesn't
go like that especially if you're a guy
and you get to a point in life where you
have options do you know what I'm saying
now you may not take your first
preference but another person may come
and you know you'll be happy to be with
them so I think there's a lot of layers
that come into this spot you have
something to say
I do
I don't want to be rude
anything like that but I think that one
of your issues may also be the fact that
you seem like you're quite far removed
from culture with them because it's not
that I don't I don't think that you're
black or not but you've mentioned manga
you've mentioned your education I can
see how you're speaking like your
composure on the first day on First
Impressions it does feel like you
probably would not relate to these
people in terms of culture and I think
that's one of the problems that people
usually have with interval interracial
datings that they don't understand that
race comes with culture and if you don't
connect on that or if you're not
open-minded enough to connect on that
it's not going to work so I would say
probably if I'm somebody that is super
in touch with my African culture and I'm
this way and that way in that way
actually you may be somebody that isn't
attractive to me not because of what you
look like and because you're smart it's
just because you may just not get me
because I may just like to dance a bit
too much or I mean like Africa music
that you may not like or may want to eat
this and you won't like it so there's
like build friction in understanding
I would say this in um Mike's defense
here as someone that I lived in the
states as well right for I did the whole
college football and all of that yeah
it it bro like what kind what culture
are you talking about bro because
there's the stripper culture that I'm
sure that any sensible black guy who it
has done you know gone to school and
made something of his life why would he
want to associate with that and
unfortunately that is prolific
and that is so prolific that is over
here but black culture is not stripper
culture and what it is I'm not I never
said Black Culture stripper I said what
culture and then I said stripper culture
no no no you're assuming I'm saying
Black Culture I'm not I'm just
explaining for example like
how do I say this without being rude
like coconut
you know where you may be a black person
but you're way more inclined towards
White culture which means that actually
as a black person sometimes as well in
your own culture you'll be looking and
thinking that don't make sense it almost
feels like just how and I'm not saying
this is the truth about him but I'm
saying on First Impressions I would
probably say yeah you feel like you
probably won't get what it means to be
black from my side you've gone over to
the other side let me let me let me just
say something I'm going to let you speak
next here let me say one thing yeah um
this whole culture thing even
particularly in the UK I think it's a
load of [ __ ] to be honest I think
that this whole uh uh black British
culture or Black Culture I really see
when you look at it it's like you have
to be a rapper you have to be associated
with crime or something you have to be
down with you know no snitching or you
have to be just down with ratchet
behavior and everything's a joke and
everything's about how well you can
dance and how many girls you can sleep
with and you know how big your your back
your back is and all of this kind of
stuff that's the culture you're talking
about bro no because yeah because as
this brother said he when he's dated
black women they've been Nigerian and
Ghanaian so what culture are you talking
about bro and guess why they were
doctors now and that's probably you
never said they were doctors
are they all doctors yeah they tend to
be doctors okay and also you mentioned
Indian and East Asian culturally those
specific countries those specific areas
they value education a lot you're a
doctor tick tick tick tick doctor
engineer tick tick tick tick doctor
engineering the military okay
do you get what I mean whereas so what
so Black Culture doesn't value education
it's not that it values education I'm
saying probably why the preference is
towards him from certain groups will
also be there right and then I'm saying
from our culture for example Black
Culture is actually a lot more
extroverted yeah we the way that we kind
of interact with each other even through
music through through our own like
traditions cultural Traditions I would
say is quite different from how other
people act and your coaching really
informs lot of your identity and who you
are so if I feel like I've got somebody
that culturally even though we're meant
to be similar if culture we don't look
like we're going to get on to be honest
I feel like that's just not for me
I'll let you talk well
um I just wanted to say is it Mike so
it's another sorry I'm gonna stuff on
your toes a little bit but I feel like
if you exist the a black woman of you
exists so I don't think it has anything
to do with like culture in terms of like
if you like anime and stuff there's
going to be a black woman that like
anime and stuff or like I get what you
mean in terms of like culture in terms
of like being
out there and whatever but some people
just aren't like that so there will be
black women that are really quiet or
really introverted and not like I don't
know dancing in carnival like I don't
know going to the Nigerian 50th or
whatever that it is I don't know
um so yeah I do feel like there are
black women that would match you
um because yeah as I said if you exist
then then they must I agree with that I
agree with that I think there's a lot
between minorities yeah in general
what kind of annoys me about this
conversation is we associate we
associate education with work culture
like a black man or whatever an
afro-caribbean man or an Asian man could
be very educated it could be an engineer
whatever whatever and he can still very
much be in touch with their culture like
if you go back home like you go back
home a lot of our people are educated
let's not dumb it down like go to
countries in Africa and the Caribbean
whatever it may be our people are very
educated what country are you from I'm
Algerian North Africa yeah so and I feel
like it's it's only really a thing like
that with a lot of first or second
Generations in the west yes like we have
this ideal of oh if he's if he's a bit
too oh he's a bit fresher
like no you can be very educated and
intellectual and a successful young
black man or Africa Caribbean man or
woman and you can still be very in touch
with your culture and I think
there's a problem when we start
separating that because when we start
separating that it's almost as if we're
saying oh for you to be educated you
need to be within the white culture and
only be a type of way which now makes
you into this and that and the other but
that's not even like I don't I've never
understood that perspective personally
because I know plenty
Highly Educated afro-caribbean men Asian
men whatever whatever and they are the
most in touch with their culture it's
unbelievable they'll be cooking at home
they'll be doing certain things they'll
be going to the the events in the whole
parties and their Church parties and
like it's a part of their life you can
be both things like let's not separate
education and and almost mask that under
the white man's umbrella yeah it's like
a it's like associating
um functional behavior and and like you
know go doing the right thing as being
white because you're saying oh it's like
when people say oh you're talking white
or you're acting white because you're
not smoking or you know doing the
stereotypical things and let me just say
this just as the you know it was kind of
weird when when the brother said oh like
they were like girl um guys like you
the funny thing is like obviously like I
know how I look in it I know I look at
stereotype stereotypical stereotypical
kind of guy yeah and I and for the most
part I am I came from that background
like do you get what I'm saying but it
wasn't until I traveled and I lived in
another country and then I started to
really be exposed to different types of
people different types of backgrounds
you know I was outside of my pond now
did you get what I'm saying that I was
forced to integrate and and mingle with
people from all different backgrounds
and then I realized that this culture
that the novel was talking about which
I'm not trying to attack you for it but
I think a lot of people have this
mindset and it's a lot of people that
haven't really really broadened their
Horizons and that culture is is alive
bro do you get what I'm saying that that
culture because just as the young lady
said in the middle you can be educated
you can do the right thing you don't
have to be associated with Drilling and
trapping and be very much all about in
the empowerment of your people and and
uplifting your chart you know I mean and
I know people like that because I've
I've gone outside of the box and I've
made sure that I don't alienate people
that are quote unquote educated lames
because that's that's the thing that
I've heard many times that all is either
a black guys either a Pookie a fog or
educated lame or like or Square like why
is it because in my opinion I feel like
and I know a lot of people won't agree
with this but I feel like being a black
guy is the hardest thing is the hardest
job for out of all men on the planet you
know what I'm saying because we're
stereotyped to the Max and then if we if
we just talk about the dating element
dating within our community is already
difficult because we're expected to be
that stereotype if you're not that
stereotyped then it's kind of like
you're weird and then you're kind of
alienated in a way yeah obviously not by
all but the general consensus is he's
not cool do you get what I'm saying and
then when you when you date outside your
race first of all most women outside you
outside our race don't really want to
date black men it may not be because
they feel black men are ugly or whatever
but because of social engineering the
reinforcements of the stereotypes and
black men are lazy they make baby mamas
that all they do is smoke pot like all
that kind of nonsense bro it's a very
very difficult game to play do you get
what I'm saying and I feel like
like every everybody just needs to be
have a level of empathy for everybody
just the same way black men need to have
empathy for where black women are coming
from and vice versa to get them saying
so like yeah it's a difficult one as
many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible